joining us now North Carolina
congressman mark meadows Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz bold members of
thankfully the one group in Congress
that keeps their promises stands on
their principles the freedom caucus
congressman meadows let me begin with
you first let's talk about the meaning
of getting Baghdady but more importantly
you're even Republicans critical the
president's policy in Syria but it was
this president that took away the rules
of engagement and beat the caliphate
completely in Syria now they got its
leader yeah a little eater of Isis well
it was it was a good day for America it
was a good day for the free world and it
was certainly a great day for the
president and his decisiveness on taking
out not just the number-one guy but the
number-one and number-two guy in terms
of terrorist activities in Syria you can
you can criticize the president for his
Syria policy but let me just tell you it
looks pretty good on Monday after the
weekend in terms of not only are we
protecting the oil fields but we're
we're going after terrorists and you
know those pictures you showed earlier
about the beheadings and all the things
we can remember that that was in our
living rooms and yet it has not been a
comic common occurrence since this
president has been in office so I just
want to thank the president's for his
decisiveness yeah and and back gates
then we go to the witch hunt I have read
on this program again and again Politico
they confirmed in fact there was
election interference 2016 by Ukraine
for three years now we've heard about
the dangers of foreign interference in
our elections here we have a country
admitting it and you got a vice
president at the time bragging about
leveraging our tax money to get a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired we found out
was paying his own son millions with no
experience in Ukraine oil energy or gas
why on earth would they be paying hunter
Biden all that money with zero
experience I bet you'd like to get paid
that money for knowing nothing well I
hope I know a little more than nothing
but I would say that you know hunter
Biden is not exactly the kind of guy you
expect to go and resolve international
disputes according to reporting by The
New Yorker he hasn't even resolved
own dispute with Hertz rental car for
leaving a crack pipe in in a crashed
vehicle so not exactly an international
man of mystery but I think what you see
Shawn is that Donald Trump is innocent
and the deep state is guilty and and
when you've got mr. Durham out there
with an investigation that transitioned
from an administrative review to a
criminal investigation that is a hat tip
that there was some catalyzing event
that caused the Attorney General and mr.
Durham to seek the ability to have the
criminal process at their disposal I
also think Durham probably frightens the
deep state a lot more than even the FISA
review because the Durham investigation
is the investigation that goes deepest
into the Obama White House and so that's
where I think you'll see people like
clapper and Brennan implicated and you
see and they're all trying to get out
ahead of this story we saw it with with
Comey but you're right because you can't
have as Andy McCarthy says the
counterintelligence investigation
without the president knowing that
president would be Obama I want to know
what he know knew and when he knew it
let me ask you this congressman meadows
we've got the IG report coming out on
the heels of that we're going to get the
Durham report what are you expecting
Americans are going to hear and how
shocked will they be at their findings
well I think the findings will be
breathtaking I can tell you that many of
the allegations that the president has
made over the last three years and the
genesis of this whole investigate the
investigator process will actually
provide fruit where where the American
people will start to say not only was
the president's campaign spied upon but
then there was a covert operation to try
to cover all this up now you mentioned
one thing earlier Sean and that was
about Ukraine and you talked about a
political article but we've got even
better evidence than that we have
congressional transcripts of Nellie ore
which indicated that the only connection
to some of her sources was Lucian Co
from the Ukraine and so if Adam Schiff
wants to get to the bottom of this let
let me just tell you the president is
innocent I've been
now eight witnesses 60 hours the
president is innocent we need to shut
this down but we do need to investigate
the origins and there is a Ukraine
problem and it's a Ukraine problem with
the Democrat and the president was
asking to get to the bottom of the
interference that all these people
thought told us we need to care about
for three years last word Matt Gaetz he
got about twenty seconds the strongest
evidence to me that Ukraine was involved
is from a court in the Ukraine a court
in the Ukraine found that there were
improper actions by the Ukraine to get
involved in the u.s. elections organized
rain determined that election
interference took place in how their
country against our elections correct
checkmate is gonna get interesting
buckle up every Republican better vote
no on Thursday we're watching